in the last video we established that if
we say a pop the rate of change of a
population with respect to time is going
to be proportional to the population we
were able to solve that differential
equation find a general solution which
involves an exponential that the
population is going to be equal to some
some constant times e to some other
constant times time in the last video we
assumed time was days so let's just
apply this just to just to feel good
that we can truly model population in
this way so let's use it with some
concrete numbers and once again you've
probably done that before you probably
started with the assumption that you can
model with an exponential function and
then you use some information some some
conditions to figure out what the
constants are we probably did this
earlier in precalculus or algebra class
but let's just do it again just so we
can feel
feel that this thing right over here is
useful so let's give you some
information let's say
that at time equal zero the population
is equal to
100 insects or whatever we're measuring
the population of and let's say
that at time
equals
let's say at time
equals 50
the population so after 50 days the
population is 200
so notice it doubled after 50 days so
given this information can we solve for
c and k and encourage you to pause the
video and try to work through it on your
own
so this first initial condition is
pretty straightforward to use because
when t is equal to zero p is a hundred
so we could say
we could say let's just use
so based on this first piece of
information we could say that 100
must be equal to
c
c
times e
times e to the k times zero
well that's that's just going to be e to
the zero
well e to the zero is just one so this
is just the same thing as c times one
and just like that we have figured out
what c is so now we can write
we can now write that the population is
going to be equal to
100
100
e
to the kt and so you can see expressed
this way our c is always going to be our
initial population
so e to the k t
e
to the k
t
and now we can use the second piece of
information so our population is 200
let's write that down so our population
is 200
when time is equal to 50 after 50 days
so 200 is equal to
100
e
100 e
to the
k
times 50 right t is now 50. so we can
let me just write that times
k times 50. now we can divide both sides
by 100
and we will get
2
is equal to e to the 50 k
e to the 50
k
then we could take the natural log of
both sides natural log on the left hand
side we get the natural log of 2 and on
the right hand side the natural log of e
to the 50 k well that's just going to be
that's just that's the power that you
need to raise e to to get e to the 50 k
well that's just going to be 50k
that's just going to be 50k all i did is
took the natural log of both sides
notice that this equation that i've just
written expresses the same thing natural
log of 2 is equal to 50k that means e to
the 50k is equal to 2 which is exactly
what we had written there and now we can
solve 4k divide both sides by 50 and we
are left with
k
is equal to the natural log of 2
natural log of 2
over 50
over
50.
and we're done we can now write the
particular solution that meets that
meets these conditions so we can now
write that our population and i can even
write our population as a function of
time
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to
100
100
times
e
to the now k is natural log of 2 over
50. so i'll write that
so natural log of 2
over 50
and then that times t
and so if you assume population is going
or rate of change of population is going
to be proportional to population you
assume this information right over here
this function is what is going to
describe your growth of population